uh unhelpful advice I'm hopeful vise
with Bobby
kalila Paul banks all right guys I'm a
huge fan I know this question seems
pretty tame compared to some of the
stuff you usually talk about but I had
nobody else to turn to my my problem is
that my girlfriend can't sing now
usually this isn't such a big deal but
the problem is my girlfriend wants to be
a professional singer she is a
hard-working she's dedicated a lot of
energy and time into practice and
lessons
she's also traditionally attractive
beside despite this she can never seem
to get an opportunity to perform
professionally and doesn't know why she
thinks it's because she's a person of
color but the reality is she completely
tone-deaf
she spent money to get semi-professional
recordings of her herself and it still
doesn't register I try to be as
supportive as I can be and keep the
shadowplay to minimum should I just be
straight up with her and ruin her dream
or just stay out of it I just feel like
she could use she could be devoting her
time and money to something more
fruitful Wow his name is Dee I've done
that with um there was a stand-up detta
I did in it okay and she was [ __ ]
terrible and for six months I would say
yeah you're good just keep working and
then one day I just realized she doesn't
have it any of it and I just got out of
the situation you know you know it's you
got it you can't support me to
mediocrity can't below wind up with
somebody's ass and tell them that
they're good or do you think you'll I I
mean I don't know I mean I would lie
yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't I would never
be comfortable you know [ __ ] on
somebody's dream but yeah but even Paul
but just listen even if let's suppose
they were absolutely tone-deaf and just
had no business whatsoever they don't
know anything about songwriting or
anything I see what you're saying though
he doesn't have to be the one to break
the news
at some point life might do that well
and and I would say yeah life will like
it Rob if she's terrible then it's just
not really gonna work out but he could
also take you know creative angles and
say like why don't we use you know some
auto-tuned yes that what do you mean
what a shadow play I've heard this arm
well there's a song called shadow play
yeah and I don't know what it means from
the song but I use it you know in
terminologies you know and to me I just
made up the meaning of the word so the
meaning to me is doing stuff that's kind
of lying but not blatant but not boring
helping someone out in a subtle lie
right okay can it also be like being
manipulative but white-white minute like
being just kind of like it's not your
intentions aren't you know awful or bad
you're just being playful yeah but you
have to do what you have to do shadow
play in many circumstances in life I
don't know like am i why do I not know
this term yeah I mean I isn't that
that's a Joy Division all right shadow
play yes yeah I don't know as much as I
should know yeah but but when you listen
to the lyrics you don't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about right so I just
used it it's a great term yeah no I
really like this term yeah yeah i'll
propagate that and credit you yeah yeah
but uh i also just kind of I don't even
identify with the impulse that this
guy's having to kind of like I don't
know you know I feel like if someone is
happy and they're your partner I feel
like if if you desperately need them to
be making money to help support like a
child you have then then you might have
to give him tough love about like this
is not practical you're not gonna make
money doing that but if this is
something that's making this you know
girl happy then I think you should just
be encouraging and not like like what's
what's your beef but what about are you
worried when you found out that the girl
didn't have it in comedy did that turn
you off did her lack of talent turn you
off persevere well it was it was an
unrequited situation okay she wouldn't
[ __ ] me why I thought she was well yeah
I could I want to I could bless her name
on right now I'm not gonna do it now on
but she was the one also that I took to
that Fox party and she gave her business
to the president of Fox I'm like what
the [ __ ] you doing you [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean you don't you don't
agree with a date to a [ __ ] Fox party
and she leaves the table and goes to the
president who the [ __ ] are you yeah and
I dragged her from the table here we go
I'm so sorry right now Gregor this is
not how you make it yeah yeah you get an
agent and you do the Tonight Show you
know and then eventually people ask you
to do [ __ ] did you ever watch the
episode where Joe Rogan was talking to
Brendan Schaub are you Joe Rogan fan I
love Joe yeah so he that when he told
Brendan to not be in the UFC anymore oh
yeah that was intense that was really I
was like uncomfortable yeah and then
what did Brendan say he took it really
well if I remember
but yeah Joe was just kind of like I saw
your last fight and I don't think you
have this like I don't think you have
this mentally I think was the gist he
was saying and it was really tough love
but it came across as the good kind like
it seemed like very good loving life
advice to his body and obviously it's
like things have gone very well for
Brendan so it's a very costly sport too
you know where it's um it would it would
warrant that kind of conversation where
you're like hey dude your life's on the
line maybe consider not getting your
brain bashed in anymore so I just got
goosebumps when you said that hmm
because I didn't realize that that
conversation had happened I don't know
Brendan Schaub from UFC
I know Brendan Schaub as a comedian and
he's good he's good huh right he's
getting better he the other day he
pulled up in his brand-new Porsche huh
you know I'm being this is listen to why
cackling all right he pulled up to the
comedy store and you know usually comics
when they pull up the comment so you
can't park there
only the best park there mm-hmm like I
talked her Rogan Park you know Thalia we
all get to park there but Brendan just
went right in got out of the car and
they all your God they you know like
she's a part of it and in my head I do
know that Brendan was a fighter and
never saw me was fights but it's so
crazy to think that he reinvented
himself yeah by doing something else and
Joe probably saved his life
and that's when when you said that I got
[ __ ] goosebumps and Joe probably also
saw a bunch of other things that he was
capable of doing because I bet you
anything if it was a guy who didn't have
a lot of other types of potential yeah
and it was just this like raw fighter
and it's really all he had going you
know you'd be a little bit more cautious
to tell him to stop making a living yeah
but he probably saw Brandon as someone
funny and you know good on a mic and all
these things that he is now I don't know
why and I'm sure Joe was gonna hear
about it cuz I'm gonna say this now but
I can I'm so still so intimidated by him
you know in a way when I see him he
always says hi he always hugs me one
time he kissed me in the cheek right
I've heard him talk about me on his
podcast like people gave me clips yeah I
hope I saw Bobby leaner and he said
killed it in the or you know so there's
no I mean we're friends but there is
just something because of the fact that
you know it's either he's an alpha male
and I'm not or he was a headliner when I
started but there's something going on
psychologically that when I'm around him
I'm aware that I'm around him I'm not
like that with Dana Carvey or anybody
out like anyone big it's him and Marc
Maron is the same way is how far is it
just that he's very comfortable in his
own skin
he's a very knowing man he's a very
brilliant intelligent guy he's very
smart and I think maybe you think he's
always gonna have something back to say
to you if you were to like misspeak
maybe no that's not what it is either do
you have someone in your life that you
feel that same way about where you're
like whoa um I don't know why he's a
peer of mine but you have that reverence
like I've had it yeah I don't have it
that I can think of right now but I've
definitely had it yeah okay good
yeah like looking up to somebody and I
think it was it was uncomfortable at the
time to be that sort of in awe of a peer
yeah but then I resolved it yeah I think
you just have to you know love yourself
and love them right you know it's
getting better I'm not saying I mean
because before I couldn't say anything
yeah like 15 years ago I would
okay okay it's so funny that you say
that because you guys have such like
you've had bonding experiences with Joe
when you almost got killed at the strip
clubs again oh I don't know I've heard
about that so yeah I think that's Chris
you were and it was you it was here yeah
see that's a good story
that was you not that you were
inadvertently generating the the danger
and Joe was like no but you know what
can I just say this I was 20 I'm 47 I
must have been 25 years old mmm when
that happened I was and also if you see
photos of me at 25 I look like I'm 11
[Music]